alors oui on s'est réconciliés bien non
oui le pen une plaque commémorative dans
l'affairé c'est le pen et bernard henri
lévy absolument j'ai alors c'était
formidable ma façon d pas non plus qu'on
finisse tous les deux en vieux couple a
donc je vous propose 10 une solution
pour qu'on se déteste à nouveau aller ça
s'appelle les questions qui fâchent
direction tayssir ouais ça dure ça va
être très dur dit ça vous fait pas un
peu tard là pour vous cette édition
samedi soir
oui
jean-rémy l'histoire vox populi
ouais et vos jambes ça va oui oui oui
j'ai j'ai un tout petit peu éclatée mais
varices en masse en banane tout à
l'heure avec les gens mais ça va dites
moi vous n'avez jamais pensé à mourir
avant pierre desproges pour être culte
c'est drôle ça ça me fait pas vivre du
vin parce que je suis en deuil
enfin deux pierres il y avait de la
place pour deux et même trois coluche
aurait pu résister et même thierry le
luron et tous ces gens qui disaient
rictions parti ne me dérangeait pas du
tout
on va te surpasser ça vous fait quoi guy
d'être moins populaire que jamel
debbouze aujourd'hui je crois pas que je
sois moins populaires plus âgés qui ont
la merde je vais plus rien à voir la
semaine prochaine
me voue une admiration qui a l'air
sincère et époque parce que je trouve
que c'était ne pas faire du racisme à
l'envers
mais parmi les comiques comme ils disent
que j'apprécie il ya lui et un autre qui
est moins médiatique qui s'appelle
fellag et c'est ces deux personnes qui
me font beaucoup rire vous pensez
qu'avec le retour des années 70
alertés vers la mode de revenir à la
mode mais gêné la mode me suis-je
les hautes pressions qui marche pas
parce que comme vous revenez tout cela
ne marche pas je voulais vous demander
si vos poches sous les yeux c'était pour
ranger vos clés sauf que ça marche pas
vraiment ça marche pas vraiment mais
c'est vrai que c'est presque une tare
familiales ont tendance à avoir un peu
de la norme ça va bien mais on me dit
que j'avais un regard assez exposé notre
ciel marche pas que vous arrivez de
teracent au vous avez un petit peu
grossi depuis la dernière fois là j'ai
perdu aux voix tranquille où j'ai pas
fait exprès à là on va vraiment se
fâcher avec celle là a les mains
allons-y dites moi qui le viagra ça
marche ou pas moi je prends plutôt qu
isabelle le truc qu'on donne aux
militaires pour les calmer fournir vos
murs l'accord suisse besoin de première
que diagrammes et oui on n'est pas
facile ça va bien nous dit qu'elle est
quelle aurait été la question qui tu
aurais vraiment fâché la question qui
m'aurait vraiment fâché est-ce que
tu veux remplacer ma fille dans
l'émission grâce à céder une question
qui me fâche mois
bien des choix de ma part on va
maintenant y arrivera par alors